pastor lee curtis childs faces
allegations of misconduct how would i
describe honk for jesus
the title alone just made me curious
it is
[ __ ] insane
honk for jesus save your soul is the
story of the first lady of a southern
baptist mega church and how she and her
pastor husband attempt to rebuild their
congregation after a scandal for ninety
child her identity is very connected to
being the first lady lee curtis wants
his church back he loves the limelight
he loves the spectacle
so he hires this documentary film crew
to get him back up on that stage
oh boy uh we can edit around that
right her goal is really to revive their
church i think she's willing to do a lot
you ain't really getting that many beeps
baby i mean you know
within reason she's not selling ass
anybody
[Applause]
we had actors who could do the insanely
funny regina hall it's hysterical you
have a blessed one and you have a
blessing
i love sterling he makes me laugh so
much
this movie does a wonderful job of
showing the benefits that the church has
had in the community but then you also
see a level of opulence which shows you
how mickey picky shady the church can be
ultimately the film is about the
reconciliation of faith with reality
hallelujah hey man
you agree that i'm in all the people on
the internet say hey man
[Music]
get your tickets now can i get an amen
amen
[Music]
you